ポケモンソードシールドが出てから目が覚めている時間はほぼずっとやってますからを
社長です
[音楽]
正しいです時に皆様空気法って知っていますでしょうか
ドラえもんの秘密道具にもあるんですけども空気を超えてバーンと出す奴がありまして
枝がいろんなのでてるんですよもちろんどれもポイントも出てるしな僕も昔て超巨大な
空気砲を作ったことがあるんですけども派以外のそれの何がすごいやつがあったって
後悔買ってみました
こちら今中に入っております肋骨ものってことだし
me
か言う
うんいっはぁっはぁっはぁっ
ああいうときどちらお名前がセカコイでてね0ブラスター
国家マイクラバットでよくある空気法っぽいんですけどもなんかヤバいのが付いてる
けどこのように謎のへ行きたいが付いてるんだよ空気法で今まで液体なんでついちゃっ
たとちょっとパパ忍があった組家でちょっと a 書いてるんで選んでいきましょう
ripe lejoy きゃりぱてぃらんっ
ガー
さあやっぱりいつも売ったら音が出るとメグだらーんということでしょ
ちょっとここ男女はなにこれええハウスベイカープロダクションでなんだウエーブの2
つ合体未来のできますねよくわからんすけどあの僕は知ってるんですよ海外製の持って
セミナーが今のぶっ飛んでるねこれまたが普通の8にすごいと思うんですよね開けて実
は港めちゃくちゃ難しいこと
3帰ってるんですけどなんかスカ学的なのかの部屋
アンティメイクって
分かりません女性は空気を打つだけなんてなんとなくやってみましょうか
ただ2空気法って空気なんて目に見えないんですけどこれに完成何か見えそうな感じが
あったって化する目に見える空気法素敵ですね炭酸6つもいるんだから炭酸6個
僕の中で炭酸4つ以上はもうかなり高価力と言って間違いないと思ってるねもう知らん
す
よこれ空技方までいえブットになって俺全然それぞれ覚悟してもいいぐらいだと思って
いればさあ入りました
調べてやってみたねってど12ft って書いてあるんですよ1フィットどれぐらいだ
というと30センチなんで
30かける中だから単四メートルから飛ぶんじゃねぇかな終わりません
それでも電池入っていうかどこがお勧動くか
[音楽]
ぷっ
なんだこれ
そんな長く出ることあるこれねー
[音楽]
音はいらんなんつーわけで早速このわけのわからない小液体入れていこうと思います
なんのこっちゃわからんですがね俺この一定
怖いな入れますうーんあとはなんとだけってみましょう
[音楽]
はぁ車の場合はではあれでもなんかねえ
やばいやばいくっ
ぶち破ったしますっ
ホッケーまあすごい
も春待ってる煙がとバーン
わかるなんと見せたい公庫
ええええええ
開けができたほ10まあすごいすごいすごい
4どうぞ
うわーっ色合いもすごいでももらおう
アークちょっと部屋暗くしました暗いほうが分かりやすい気がする
これ
俺うんほい
ほらほらほらーすごいすごい
弊社製の山
[拍手]
[音楽]
是非とも見ていただきたいいきます
これ
ちょっと見えてるのはわかるんですけどすごいすごいよ
あっこれ危ない来ないよね体には害内容熱やたでよかったしなメス
この見てめっちゃは彼の掘ってるよ
[拍手]
[音楽]
いやーすごいすごいすごいじゃあすごいよこれ
まずれすごいよ
[音楽]
ほらホロホロホロすごいよ電池だけで実いてそれがで言ってのはマジすごいと思いまし
た衛兵に打てるかねこれで
[音楽]
すごいすごいすごいよ
やべぇー演技遊んじゃたいというまずで素晴らしい空気法です
[拍手]
[音楽]
a にゃさんじゃやばいやばいばいいやおんもーるろう
これたぶんなんですけど初見でこれ見ると超強いと思うんですよと呼び出すこの
目に見える空気法でず近くにいる人たちを脅かしてこようと思いますでは iphone
[拍手]
[音楽]
にゃは
いい時とか
ああああああ
95新宿中国をとってこれ見てね
はにゃ
ええええええ
ん
えっなんと分京王
[音楽]
それぞれ2月だけ
もういいんだぜ
dee
[音楽]
バッハ
[拍手]
止めないヤブチュールツアー
やめろっつってんだろー
ああああああ
me
うううう
ni
car
ああっあった